all right dominic
dominic where'd you grow up where are
you from originally pasadena
pasadena california and uh tell me about
your family you both your parents
uh well they just split up recently but
they should have split up
like 30 years ago oh i see how was your
childhood uh
terrible in what ways i was molested by
a neighbor family
and some neighbors uh
and my brother just abused me he beat me
my parents weren't there
uh they're doing their own thing and so
like i was left alone for like weeks at
a time
what were your parents doing oh uh just
cheating on each other just with the
different
people different places yeah so they
finally split up now
oh yeah what kind of kid were you in
high school
uh a bad one
uh i was
yeah uh i was just getting into trouble
uh beating up people
uh getting beaten up myself still at
home by my older brother
um
yeah you finished high school yeah
what did you get into after that uh i
went to college
for a short amount of time
um but that was just
it was brief with brief college not even
didn't get a degree
yeah how old are you now 31 31
and drugs started for you at what point
oh high school
what drugs were you playing around with
everything
and today you're into what everything
yes i don't care
just anything you're living
on skid row now yeah where are you at in
a tent or
i'm at the weingarten well you're in the
rain guard yeah i just got in
see if you have a roof over your head
yeah finally but you've been
i've been on the streets for like three
years oh yeah well uh the streets of
skid row for three years
and the streets of uh earned out
for like four how does irwindale com
compared to skid row
or vice versa it's a whole different
world it's uh out there it's just uh
it's more woods and it's uh the riverbed
and uh it's just a whole different
world than down here much more isolated
oh yeah way more
isolated here it's very social oh yeah
here there's people everywhere
you can't get away from people well
there you get away from people and you
could
go missing and not be found yeah yeah
and uh the relationship do you have with
your family is it
you still had contact with them i just
got back into contact with my father
my mom no uh
my older brother is dead to me
um and the rest of the
ascendant family i don't talk to them
so i mean if you if you point a finger
at
what got you into this situation where
you're homeless and
you're you're using heroin among the
other things
what would you credit for for getting
you into this situation
the parenting the relationship with your
brother yeah
but a combination of myself too because
uh
not stupid but um i don't know due to
just addictive personality traits
i just led me down the wrong path
was one of your parents into alcohol or
drugs yeah
my mom's a big alcoholic oh i see yeah
do you think your addiction is kind of
inherited for
from her yeah yeah
how do you support yourself now i've
clicked hands
recycling yeah pretty much click hands
[Music]
find stuff that people throw away
repurpose it
resell it um
[Music]
pretty much everyone knows me as guy
that will do whatever for money
so like uh i'll get people that want me
to beat somebody up so i'll do that
um
like breaking into places
uh broke into the brewery
uh stuff like that
just whatever it takes to get much money
yeah
did you have friends yeah well
acquaintances yeah street street
acquaintances yeah yeah i wouldn't call
it like friends
what emotions do do you struggle with
uh
i really thought that
uh
just being here you're depressed or
angry
yeah i have uh depression yeah
chronic depression what do you worry
about
uh worry about the dog that's about it
but other than that there's no like i've
already lived my life
ah
i didn't make it i never thought i'd
make it this far really yeah i never
ever expected to make it this far like
and all my friends
growing up they're just like oh yeah
you're gonna be dead way before you hit
20
and i was just like yeah yeah i'm gonna
be dead way before i hit 20
and then so when i hit 20 and then so on
and so forth until i'm down 31
it was a big uh wow because you're so
self-destructive or oh yeah and like
everyone that i know like from high
school they're like oh
you must have slowed down and i'm like
no i haven't i've actually
picked up speed and then they're just
like what the hell like
you're still alive and i'm just like
yeah no crazy right
like i didn't see that one coming
what's been the the best time in your
life best time of my life
huh um
[Music]
probably when i was a kid and i was
still like naive to what was really
happening around me
and i didn't really understand what was
happening
it was still [ __ ] up but i just didn't
understand it yet you weren't old enough
to know what was going on yeah
what do you think this lifestyle that
you've led
has taught you about about human nature
about yourself about
about life wow that
well push them to shove people
will do anything to get what they want
uh you feel like there's a doggy dog out
there oh yeah
oh oh yeah oh
that's there's no question that it's
especially here on skid row oh yeah
like you you can't blink without someone
trying to pick your pocket
and it's like have nothing to pick and
you're still trying to pick my pocket
hey what the hell hey how smart are you
like but i'm guessing all the people
that come here are not the best of the
best
no it's it's probably the worst the
worst yeah
and you ended up homeless how did that
happen
uh you probably had a job at one point
right
no not really no no i had like little
like
little jobs that were like an hour a day
stuff like that but no real like job job
um like
like fraud and stuff was like my number
one like
fraud stuff like that money maker
way better than any job do you have kids
no you ever been in love
yes i would say yeah so yes
can you tell me about that oh um
without any details
well i just fell in love with someone
and uh they didn't turn on
who i thought they'd be yeah but i still
love that person
and uh just didn't turn out exactly how
i wanted to
yeah well that happens a lot to all of
us yeah
it happens
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
uh don't count on anybody but yourself
because you're the only person you can
trust anybody else
it could be your mother your father it
doesn't matter you can't trust it
uh overall they're looking out for
themselves
so so as far as drug use you're using
which drugs
right now fentanyl
heroin meth
weed pcp
i just picked up some dmt right now um
yeah you think you're trying to kill
yourself uh
pretty much living is trying to kill
myself
me being still alive is trying to kill
myself
because of uh just i've been conditioned
to
be this way through the years where i
don't know how to live without killing
myself
well dominic i wish you the best of luck
and uh i hope you find a way
another path for yourself yeah we do
all right thank you very much thank you
you